is the purpose of wait but why to start
kind of informing people to get them to
care before it's too late or what is
your intent with the whole like all the
content you're making the purpose in
general is for me to do something I'm
having fun at do it I spent nine years
after college doing something that was
kind of objectively a cool thing but I
was not doing what I wanted to be doing
so honestly I I was like I want to be
doing I want to be excited to wake up I
want to be excited to do my work I want
to feel like I'm playing when I'm doing
my work and this fits a lot of things
for me I'm very curious so I get to be a
constant learner
I like having great conversations with
interesting people and wait but wise
connecting me to all kinds of great
conversations I love creating like just
artistically creating so a post is a
piece of art in a way and it allows me
to kind of just yeah continually stay in
excitable mode because I can switch
topics again and again and again and I
just always very I feel like I'm in the
honeymoon phase with the the job all the
time because I switch topics and it's a
whole new planet for me so I love that
and if I didn't like it I don't think
I'm a good enough person to you should
to do it out of obligation for you know
I think this is gonna help like I I like
that I look I think I would you know but
I think I'm more than a person that
might throw money it's something good
I'm not sure I would dedicate my life
just something where I was just I felt
like it wasn't my calling wasn't
something I really was passionate about
it was something I had fun doing so that
said as way but why has gotten more
popular as I've kind of had you know
begun to dive into a lot of more kind of
intense deep topics I started to
appreciate the impact that a viral blog
post can have I appreciate it when times
like when I go to and I've spoken at a
bunch of colleges and I was it a place
like MIT and afterwards a couple
students come up and they said they're
they're going to work in one of them was
working at SpaceX and one of them is
going to work in AI next year both
because of my post and I was like you
know so I was like right there these two
are probably smarter than me both of
them they're 18 and like if they both
got work that took 120 years of human
effort going towards like
really good important things and maybe
they instead would have gone into
finance or something else so to me I was
like that's really awesome and and and
if and if that's you know two of I don't
know however many that to me is a
massive impact if I can convince really
smart people to turn their attention or
their money or their time towards
important things I think that that's
about as big an impact as I could have
as a human because me going into it
myself that's one person plus honestly
these MIT dudes are probably more
capable than I am um I think I think you
know that yeah and and just kind of
since it is a battle for kind of
awareness right now awareness of the
story that we're a part of this human
Colossus story is crazy
we woke up inside a thriller movie
mm-hmm
and you know I I use this analogy so if
human history is a thousand centuries
about 100 thousand years
okay picture every page of a is a 500
page book telling the story and every
page is two centuries okay if you're an
alien again and you pick up this book
and you're trying to understand what the
human history is like so the first 450
pages okay the first 90 thousand years
gets us to it's just hunter-gatherers
that's it
migrations and hunter-gatherers and very
very slight biological changes your year
you are bored as an alien reading the
book page 450 of the Agricultural
Revolution and you have cities and you
have the first you know you know kind of
wide scale cooperation this Colossus
takes a huge leap forward right things
start to get a little interesting that's
just the last 50 pages of the book and
things do develop in a kind of
interesting cool way if page 490 you
have Jesus you have ad starts at 10
pages ago okay and you have you know is
Lomb starts at page 493 and around page
497 you have pea realism gets rolling
then you have the Enlightenment the next
page and right at the beginning of page
500 the very last
you have the Industrial Revolution and
you have the entire kind of the Colossus
kind of like it goes on steroids the
Colossus grows up very quickly and
becomes far more powerful mm-hmm the
population balloons from less than a
billion to seven billion on page 500
alone we go from every other page before
page 500 you know transportation meant
walking running sailboats page 500 we're
going to the Space Station we're flying
around planes and cars yeah
communication on page 499 and earlier
men you know talking to people and
writing letters with your hand page 500
we have FaceTime we have you know
internet so if you're the alien reading
this book suddenly you're on page 500
and you're like and you just can't
believe what you're reading and you're
so rivet you're saying oh my god this is
the story this is what this is all been
leading to what's about to happen you
turn the page to 501 and you're just
like what is go what this something's
about two bigs about to happen here we
we all were born right right then yeah
it's crazy yeah so I think that part of
what I can do is the only reason I'm so
aware of this right now is because I
write about I think I have my jobs to
think about this okay and so I think
that part of what I can do is just take
humans that are every bit as smart as I
am and everybody's curious but it's not
their job to think about this stuff and
kind of shake them and say hey like
we're about to turn to page 501 it's
either gonna be the coolest story for
humans or it's the end this is this is
the that is a is a 501 page book and
that's it or this is the beginning of
like the new paradigm we have a new
bc-ad situation we have a BC which is
like before something you have is on
page 501 when we all became immortal and
we stand all the suffering stopped and
whatever that is and beast the BC this
will be the real BC much more important
than any religious thing it'll be the
thing before humans came into their own
that's really exciting or it'll be the
end and that'll be there'll be no more
monkey so this is the barrier in the
Fermi post right it has to be I mean I
didn't know the thing is the problem is
we're wired to think about we're wired
for a world when nothing changed ever so
when someone says this is
this is gonna be the future everything's
gonna be different it's why is to be
naive it's it to feel that that's not
like the snake oil alarm
it feels naive and it should feel that I
Eve because it used to be naive
today it actually is if you already do
is look just compare just just there's
no salesman needed here just look at the
facts of page 500 versus 499 in every
page before it this is clearly not like
every other time so yeah III think
there's a I find it exciting I'm very
happy that's always so people like the
interest in startups and technology kind
of ebbs and flows it seems and and now
for better or worse it seems to be like
people are pushing tech away like in big
quotes because they think of tech is
like just Facebook but in reality it's
so so so much more and whenever when
someone's like down on this stuff and
they're like I don't need an app to like
walk my dog or something I'm like change
your point of view and look at this
other stuff and it's crazy there's so
much going on heck is a monster god is
on the horizon running towards us right
now
and when the god gets here it's either
gonna be a really good benevolent
amazing God or a really bad God
depending on what we do right now so we
should go into tech you should go spend
your career in taking literally the
people in tech right now art are the
people who are created by God and
deciding what that God's gonna be like
when it gets here and so yes you might
you might object to the lifestyle that
some of us have that many of us have
taken on due to early tech kind of sure
different topic than saying technology
in general you know I wanna it's like no
no no if you care about people if you
care about your grandchildren you should
be focusing on this - yeah and
especially wary that the the minds in
tech right now there is good people as
they maybe they're worried about their
their their their humans their primates
and what the primate wants is Ted to is
to succeed in its own life so they are
worried about glory and trying to take
succeed and when everyone in that's
doing that you have this monster being
developed in a way that's that doesn't
larger kind of thought process here it's
just being developed to develop it
mm-hmm
that's really really scary so do you is
is there like a canon of literature
around that specific topic or is this
kind of a new idea like developing
something that i mean i guess you could
think about it as a religion basically
like how do we get past our short-term
monkey mind to care about more people
when we're developing technology I think
you know I think as humans okay yeah the
thing that when you want to really make
a change you have to you don't try to
change humans fundamentally that's not
easy what you try to do is you should
have build some kind of structure or
system that will naturally incentivize
shitty selfish humans to do the right
thing hmm this is the Elon Musk formula
and many others and so in this case but
the thing that drives humans more than
anything more than absolutely anything
is culture and because we want deeply
want to be accepted by our culture and
our system whatever society we're in we
want to be cool in it whatever Society
says these are the cool kinds of people
everyone will put all their energy to
try to be like that whatever you know
that the people around us whatever will
make us fit in and stand out and be
admired and and be attracted to the
opposite sex and and and all of this if
Society decided that money was
unattractive and that and that you know
working with your hands and living on as
little as possible really made you
awesome and that's what all the movie
characters suddenly were doing and
that's what again the opposite sex
really started to like no one's in
finance anymore we'd all be yeah working
out and trying to get out in
construction fields and be really good
the money is only big deal to us because
that's currently what you know society
has just told us matters because because
it you know it's a remnant of a world
where resources you know we're so scarce
now that's not resources aren't scarce
anymore but the values have stuck around
the value of let's let's all obsess over
resources is still here
now you have you know rich people
obsessing their whole life over getting
richer so if you want people to obsess
over AI safety right now the AI
developments a big thing because
development you know entrepreneurship is
getting rich getting getting successful
is what we value if suddenly it became
extremely cool in society to be a
philosopher thinking about them or
someone in tech obsessed with with AI
safety and we and if we if I think the
way this could happen is if people that
were aware enough of this page 500
situation suddenly they we all this fear
around it right and and all of this
excitement but all this fear and if
someone could have a breakthrough
now didn't develop and development
people would kind of almost look at kind
of suspiciously like just you know you
know are you okay that's fine but but if
someone comes out with a big a big
breakthrough in AI safety and they
became kind of Nobel Prize front page of
Time magazine you know they were
interviewed everywhere and they were the
biggest celebrity because because we
were all scared and they owe my god this
person might save us yeah kind of like
you know them people thought you know
the Manhattan Project might save us back
then or anytime there's you know fear
mmm and in humans that that takes over
everything and if you can then if you
can kind of swage that fear somehow so I
think that if you really wanted this to
happen I think that you need I mean
someone like you know Elon Musk who's
really prominent but also really
concerned with AI safety that helps I
think many people like me trying to make
this these points helps but again it's
not telling people you should want
safety to be a good person it's saying
this is the big challenge of our time
this is the the great you know decision
moment we're about to be at this is the
great filter or not and who's gonna be
the hero that can figure this out this
is the great problem this is it if the
developments happening automatically
it's like a wave coming in tsunami
coming towards us like who wants to be
the hero who wants to be the person that
saved all of us who you know the
everything in the world be named after
them they'll be basically a god in the
future world that they came up with a
solution if we can
that will happen if people understand
the reality and if people if that
happens then you'll see all kinds of
people all thinking about it and forming
clubs and it'll be the coolest thing to
be going in to be that people gonna be
the most noble thing you can go into and
the and the raddest so you know the
smartest people it's like oh you're
really smart you should go into that
then you know the Cancer Research now
might be that you know it's something
like that totally so and so when you
were a kid who is the person who you're
like man that person is so cool like if
I could just be like them then I'll have
made it a meal Wallner basically asked
this question like where they're
bloggers or writers that you looked up
to it as communicators um I don't think
as a kid writing was on my radar as much
as a kid I think I wanted to be like I
wanted to compose music in a way I
wanted to be like Andrew Lloyd Webber or
like Billy Joel or like the Beatles I
think that when I was like eleven would
have done at some point I wanted to be
the president I had like a little ego
Easter knew then that disappeared by
about actually became the class
president and that when I was like in
like middle school high school okay I
was 18 I was like I'm not gonna do more
of this this was never campaigning again
yeah and and also being a class
president is a useless job you're not
really doing anything you're raising
small amounts of money for one thing or
two things that are already gonna be
funded somehow anyway and it that's
actually I think a microcosm of a lot of
real politicians lives not the
politicians as a unit don't together
have a lot of power but each trying to
be a senator forever
I feel like I can do more actually in a
lot of ways and have a lot more fun so
that disappeared and then then I meant
that then I was back in creative Lane
where I want to eat either music or
writing you know one of those and when I
first started to think about blogging
out she was blogging on the side for
like six years before I started wait for
why I didn't look necessarily to well
early on Bill Simmons you know in
college I was one of in college right
when he was at his peak popularity big
sports fan Boston so I was you know I
mean big Bill Simmons reader and I
wouldn't say I necessarily wanted to
mimic his specific style
but it was his kind of personality
integrity just the fact that he would go
on and just be himself and be colloquial
and be kind of like fun like the way he
would write an email to his friends is
how he would write an article that
resonated with me that seemed very
obvious
I was like that that is clearly the way
to go if I ever a writer when I started
my blog it was just it wasn't even a
question I wasn't gonna try to be a
journalist or have any kind of formula I
was gonna go and just try to be a fun
writer
well that just came with the internet
too it did exactly so it was it was a he
was one of the first really famous ones
but um but but so and then I looked at
you know other successful bloggers who I
respected you know Allie Brosh at
hyperbole and a half and Randall Munroe
and you know Jason Kottke and these you
know certain certain blogs that I
thought were great and thing I really
appreciated about them is they were all
very unique kind of like molded to the
person's personality who made them like
they they were just clearly a reflection
of the person the person wasn't trying
to be a brand or anything different they
were just kind of like being their best
selves you know in in writing form you
know drawing form and so again it wasn't
that I think I was very adamant about
trying to actually not look at other
styles because I was like I want to do
my exact style because that's what I
think it is the key actually but it was
the integrity of these styles that I saw
there people use and I think it really
kind of stuck with me as it made it very
clear that like I'm gonna double down on
my own style versus trying to fit into
any other kind of form yeah
totally in like integral that I haven't
read your old block is it still up the
year old so it is somewhere it's called
a underneath the turban okay it is it's
very few people have read it it's a it
was just me it was much more classic
blog style stuff I would write about my
day I'd rant about something I'd write a
list of things I didn't understand in
the world so was it as thoroughly
researched as okay so there was what
another Twitter question a nice Geary s
basically what styles and techniques do
you use to learn things quickly enough
to I think you've talked about it like
getting from basically to like level
five and an ability to communicate you
know like this is a I this is why it's
interesting this is why you should care
what do you use to go from like reading
a I on Wikipedia to writing you know a
ten thousand or what is it like thirty
thousand word post about it
what do you do yeah yeah so the Internet
is a real godsend to a curious person or
to a blogger trying to order
procrastinating or do a procrastinator
to a lot of things yeah but if you can
consider like one through ten knowledge
on something ten is like you know the
world's leading expert you know phd's
get you to like maybe seven or an eight
my goal is I'm starting a two or three
as a layman you know if I'm really
curious layman I'll be to 3x already
known and I don't give myself up to like
you said a five maybe a six I becoming
an eight would take years I would have
to focus in on one topical only I'd
rather become a six on fifty topics than
an eight on three you know or ten on one
so that four that's me not everyone some
people the thing they love is being a
nine or a ten and knowledge that's just
I don't that doesn't excite me that much
it would be great it's just it's the
lesser of excitement um so and then and
then my goal as a blogger is to after
I've gotten to level six to then package
everything I just learned and the road I
just went down I basically look at the
road I went down and said if I could do
this road again how could I do it
efficiently now how can i and I and how
can I package this in a way that doesn't
just take someone down this road
efficiently and thoroughly to get them
to where I am but does it in a way more
fun way then I just had let's have I
want the reader to have a lot more fun I
wanted to features yeah lot more picture
is Moore's more kind of storytelling and
and just funnier and just more enjoyable
than what I just did so um it's it's
it's that I just went down a road now
let me take this road and make it
awesome and that's my job and I got a
new road then I don't know whatever so I
think the question is about how do I go
down my road to get for myself from that
to to a six huh and the so I start with
Wikipedia or general kind of googling I
would all do is I'll google the question
I have so if I want to understand
cryonics if I you know whatever it is I
look Google what is cryonics
cryonics versus cryogenics at home and
we all have heard those terms and I'll
Google cryonics scam and I'll Google
does cryonics work and I'll Google have
heard Peter Thiel said something so I'll
say Peter Thiel cryonics and I'll Google
Alcorn chronicles I heard there was a
company core and I'll Google um how many
cryonics companies are out there cost of
cryonics I'll Google these each in a
different tab hmm then in each tab I'll
basically without even looking all those
open every link you know you know eight
eight links on each tab so I'll go but
like seventy or eighty links okay and
you know among those are all the four
were different Wikipedia articles and
then a bunch of just articles written
you know secondary stores kind of
articles just you know written and
Gizmodo and other places like that so
none of those alone is like an awesome
source
yeah it's that on the whole the the
group of those articles will give me
will will give me a foundational
understanding Wikipedia is good for a
foundational understanding it'll give me
a foundational understanding it'll also
tell me what we what the big opinions
are I'll realize where the big
disagreements are where the kind of
uncertainties are and it just kind of
like Orient's me in general and I'm like
okay I I now understand what I need to
start learning even and so are you
writing notes yourself at this point are
you trying to communicate this to you
know like your girlfriend or your
friends so you actually know that you're
understanding it instead of just reading
words I am I have a big document open
that I'm pulling quotes that's really
interesting or fact or stat or an
opinion and then when I see in a counter
opinion I'll find that opinion I'll put
it underneath it into the document so
they're next to each other and then I
have a lot of thoughts of my own as I'm
going I'm suddenly bursting with
thoughts and I'm bursting with metaphors
I'm saying this is a lot like you know
or I'll say cryonics is kind of like
long-term patient care or it's like
pausing you biologically it's not that
I'll just write it down right and I'll
write down all my thoughts as that goes
a lot of the best idea just couldn't
come out as you're researching and and
then depending on the topic you know
first of all sometimes it's a very
different process if I'm thinking about
procrastination and why you
procrastinate if I'm thinking about why
we care what other people think of us or
why we get into so many bad marriages
people I'm much more likely gonna be
thinking or I'm just gonna be pacing
around thinking maybe having some
conversations with friends and writing
stuff down there's less research but so
I'm specifically talking about one kind
of post idea right now which is their
heavy research post I need to kind of an
explainer post right and so at that
point I have a foundation but there's a
lot more I need to learn I'll feel very
insecure about my knowledge in many
different of these areas and I'll just
have certain things I don't understand
it all so I'll have to go deeper like
I'll I won't understand why freezing
your cells is not good but vitrify is so
I'll want to dig deeply into that so
I'll just first a look at why why water
expands when it freezes and I'll go read
about that for a half hour okay and then
I'll look at vitrification I'll realize
Oh litora Phi we vitrified embryos and
organs so how does that work what
actually goes on in the cell what goes
on in the in the actual atoms what's
happening antifreeze and I'll go into
how antifreeze works in cars to
understand what antifreeze is because
there's an antifreeze type solution is
it the same solution is it different is
it you know and I just started going
down rabbit holes up the rabbit hole
sometimes these become unproductive
because I just get curious I end up on
YouTube and like 12 hours later I'm like
watching you know like people in road
rage like fights and all but but but
then I'll call reel it in and I'll come
back and but there's just the point is
there's a lot of different depending on
how broad you want to go and I often
want to go really broad they don't go
into the Alcor websites they have this
great QA
there's this great FAQ so I'll go and
read their whole FAQ and then I'll go
but then I know that their one voice
only and they have maybe an incentive so
then I'll go read a competitor's FAQ and
I realize even all of that is silk
raunak's companies then I want to go
read a bunch of so then I'll start to
understand like what the best argument
is for cryonics and I'll understand the
science behind it and a lot of my own
thinking about how I want to frame how I
can explain this or my own I want to
track my own thought process I'll go
from skeptical to kind of like super
excited to then like a little less
excited but but a believer or something
and I want to track that so I can
because I assume a lot of readers are
gonna go through
that so I'm gonna want to like talk I
like to talk about my own where my own
heads at at the end of a post because I
feel like I brought readers here we can
almost like as a group discuss even
though I'm the only one in the room but
so then I want to go and do a hardcore
session on the skeptics what they say I
want to go just Google things like
chronic scam chronics like you know
won't work cryonics bogus science
pseudoscience others Google these things
and I'll read as many articles as I can
and it's not that I'm gonna get to the
bottom especially since a lot of times
there is no bottom right now but what I
will do is I'll have a sense of there's
a difference between the skepticism
many and they're diverse in their
viewpoints and they but there's there
seems to be some big fatal flaws and it
seems like the cryonics people aren't
acknowledging them and whatever or you
look the other way you say you know
actually the skeptics don't seem to
really understand what's going on here
they kind of seem to have a knee-jerk
reaction some of them even talk about
freezing a body which is not even that's
like what the first thing you learn when
you raise that's not what's happening in
which case I think in and I'll have a
sense of I'm like you know the the
cryonics people actually are seeming
like the more serious thinkers right
here versus the skeptics or whatever it
is but I want to understand that too
yeah at the end of that I have this huge
pile of thoughts and research and then I
go on to the next phase which is you
know outlining and then writing and then
drawing and then revising but that's by
the end of that I I know the [ __ ] out of
the topic you know it's like but but
what I'm really done and especially
since you then solidify it by outlining
it and then writing it and then
discussing it you know usually the next
week you you solidify it with a but but
by the time I'm done I mean again I'm
not a true expert and then I ask me you
know I don't know i i'm not gonna advise
a cryonics company on a new kind of
technique to use nowhere near that level
but what i can do is basically talk to
any layman and answer basically any
question they have um there's not almost
no question at the end of that where I
can't not just give you an answer but I
can explain like the science behind it
and I can't explain the different you
know the different that contrarian views
to the prevailing opinion so and this is
just the Internet this is just a pretty
smart guy on the Internet
we're not calling people you're not you
reading stuff yeah the sometimes I will
like I for example for this I called my
doctor friend who I knew would be
skeptical because I know he and I wanted
to just hear why and I wanted to kind of
play devil's advocate to his skepticism
with what I've learned and kind of set
up a mock argument between a crown
assist and a skeptic by me playing the
crown assist so I'll do that for like
the post I just did on neural link on
brain machine interfaces yeah that is so
new and there's so many different
opinions and I had access in this case
to a lot of great people that I went
through and I went to neuro link and I
met with all the founders and I met with
Moulton many of the multiple times I
talked to a bunch of other chronics I'm
a BMI people too and some sci-fi people
so I thought people I find this how bad
people are the ones who have the best
handle on things like page 500 on things
like this big picture it's crazy yeah
those people those are the people that
um that think really big picture and
they know they know about all the
different technologies versus a lot of
times the people in an industry they
have their blinders on and they're not
that great at thinking about the really
big picture a lot some of them are but
many times actually I'm talking to a
scientist I for example I talk to read
Nez Nam in this case science fiction guy
about you know brain machine interfaces
versus language you know is this the
next paradigm is language this one big
movement this with this big kind of
change and now his brain machine
interfaces like the next thing or is
there like going from is writing kind of
on that level or well he's a perfect
part we had this great conversation
about that because that's the kind of
stuff that he thinks about versus the
people I had I talked to the brain
machine interfaces industry they were
kind of like well I they just didn't
they had they didn't have much of an
answer well I think that's actually what
causes the rift between a lot of these
people because some people are so deep
in it they're engineers they care about
the practical day-to-day progress and
then there are these like writers
philosophers in the subject and they
both kind of think the other part is
like that I don't know what they're
talking about
or they're so you know the people were
there a lot of times the people in it
are so annoyed by the the the idiots who
basically lie about how quickly this is
gonna happen to people who say we're all
gonna be thinking to each other in three
years and they're so mad about that that
someone actually way closer to them but
but way but but being pretty optimistic
yeah they just group them all together
to say oh no they but but actually
know that they reject any kind of their
so dug in now on their stance that this
is gonna take a long time that they can
actually go too far at that anyway so I
am so for cryonics for example I didn't
talk to anyone else other than my doctor
friend um everything I need was on the
Internet AI I didn't talk to a soul I
read three books probably 200 articles
including you know once you get to once
you understand stuff well then you want
to get to some really hardcore science
you get to the papers I started reading
all these mindless boring papers and
read a bunch of philosophy you know
papers on this stuff so I just got deep
in but I just read for like oh maybe two
weeks and which isn't that much it's not
that much meat you really not eighty
hours of nothing of reading taking stuff
out like you can get the it's not like
you know you yeah you can get the pretty
big picture especially if it's an
industry that we're not even sure yet
there's a species were arguing about it
you can understand everyone's viewpoints
pretty well yeah and one good book like
superintelligence in the case of AI can
can give you a really really great
foundation right there and then you can
just kind of tack on information to that
foundation or poke holes in that
foundation and you end up with a solid
understanding hmm how often do you let a
post go where you're like you're doing
the research and you just can't get a
handle on it or you you feel like the
research isn't even there and you have
to stop I don't think I've ever really
done that I think um I'll often like
brainstorm a new post and then stop but
usually that's because I just get it I
suddenly am that's this this a key a
daunting thing that I'm sure all
daunting but when I'm looking at this
one particular daunting topic suddenly
every other topic sounds better the
grass is greener phenomenon if I'm
writing about life and I'm just like I
have to come up my own philosophy on
this and I'm just like imagine just
researching something in science how
easy that would be when I'm you know
just buried and you know a really thick
research trying to understand something
I said imagine if I could just sit back
and think about you know how we think
like you know or or if I'm trying to be
funny you know what when I'm doing
either of those it sounds so easy to
just try to do a funny kind of
observational comedy post and if I'm
doing one of those I'm like oh the other
ones I can just kind of be earnest I
have to like try like be witty here at
insa nightmare so I'm always switching
for that reason
really early on but what I've dug into a
research post usually I only start those
in the first place because I already
know it's a good topic because I heard
enough people talking about it and I'm
curious enough about it I know there's a
lot to say and whatever it is this gonna
be worth explaining whatever I can find
out so if I find this I'm researching
that actually like there's not really
any good answers to this that's
interesting in its own you'll be able to
say you know what like don't feel bad
about not knowing because no one knows
what this is but here's what we do know
you know that that's fine I'm fine to do
that so usually ones that pick the topic
I'm just I'm gonna explain what is out
there whatever that is and that that's
fine
and do you ever feel that you ought to
do kind of like a an anti skeptic post
you know if you fall into a YouTube
rabbit hole you can quickly come across
you know Flat Earth or any of like the
sort of related topics have you ever
felt drawn to like doing it you know a
disproving of that or any particular
crazy conspiracy theory I'm writing a
post now that is kind of taking aim at
political Dogma and just be on on all
sides and and talking about how all
these stats that you know one political
side takes is gospel I mean they're
almost always wrong because because in
and you know in an echo chamber
environment there's no kind of like
white blood cells to kill the virus and
so it just explained it just because the
scent isn't okay over there you know
it's not it's not not only is it not
valued it's very much found upon so
everyone's agreeing everyone's
confirming and you have these bad stats
to live on and so I'm trying to take a
bunch of those in this case and show
that they're not true and show why we
got there and how we think is you know
and so that's one example I've done you
know a few other times I've kind of
tried to take a contrarian view on
something that I really believe but most
of the time especially with kind of like
a research II topic I find that the
contrarian to be a contrarian you have
to have conviction you have to have
strong opinion that this is wrong
and for me if I get conviction it's
gonna be because I stole it from the can
stuff I read like I'm only getting
conviction from what I'm reading so I
could all I'm really doing in that case
is regurgitating someone else's
contrarian argument and I'd rather just
credit them and kind of present both
sides and let the readers make a
decision so it's super like what's your
stance on AI I'm like well here's this
person standing here is this person's
this one seems a little more credible to
me but who knows versus me being like
this is right I'm like but like on the
other hand if I'm talking about we
shouldn't be so dogmatic like that's
deep in me I believe that and I and I
and I think it's very much like
pervasive how dogmatic we are and it
needs to be said so there's certain
moments like that that I can I can do
that but if it's like I'm proving
disproving Flat Earth I mean I could do
that but the point is there is also like
what's that do we're gonna pick on the
the point oh oh one percent of crazies
who think this like so we can altogether
like it's fun I agree that would be a
kind of a fun thing to do but it's not
that's I it's it's it's what's the point
you know it's just we can all be like
yeah it's like great no one who reads
wait but why thinks the earth is flat
although I just I just was interviewed
on a documentary about the Flat Earth
and apparently there's like 10,000 plus
very serious flat earthers in the US
okay and they're not like the the a lot
of them are really obsessed with the
fact that they think it's science-based
why is flat earth they have all these
measurements they've done experiments
they have these you know they have all
this math and data showing it and they
and they you know they and as they seem
to have always kind of found some way
they can like create kind of a logic
loophole that makes it seem true but
they but but I was asking do they really
believe it and is it with all their
heart they're sure and they're sure that
that like this is this crazy world that
everyone is believing this I think it's
like the genetic other side of that like
snake oil coin where you're like oh I
know the secret like I get this and like
knowing the secret is this weird like
monkey sensation that makes us feel good
and different it is it's it's we all
have in us a susceptibility to
conspiracy theory it's a spectrum
conspiracy I think it goes from totally
objective on one side to bias a
confirmation bias
cherry picking you know kind of lorry
luring our way to conclusions where we
kind of already know the conclusion we
find arguments right then you can get
down the spectrum further that ends its
full schizophrenia which is everything I
see is part of this thing yeah you know
you can your brain your left brain is
powerful which is helpful in many ways
it finds a lot of finds patterns it's a
that's incredibly ingenious in a lot of
ways but it also gets us into huge
trouble because it's it's this great
lawyer it can find patterns and anything
and create an art if you want to believe
something your left brain will find the
evidence to make you believe it so
before you get to full-blown
schizophrenia where suddenly there's
this one story and everything you see is
in it and it says you get to this land
in the middle which is conspiracy land
and you know we all laugh at something
like you know all the people who think
9/11 was caused by the u.s. or the moon
landing didn't happen or flat-earthers
we don't look at ourselves in the mirror
there was a lot of times we genuinely
believe conspiracy and we will and and
you don't realize it but then you know
you're you're reading a bunch of news
that is all cater to your eternity yeah
and you don't realize that that like you
know I I've read an article the other
day about how the when it comes to like
trump and russia the left is believing a
lot of crazy [ __ ] now there's just
people out there who are just kind of
making stuff up at this point about
these ties and there's smart people
passing it around being like this is it
he's gonna this is when he goes out
there being crazy they're being crazy
because there's just no there they want
to believe something so badly and
they're so in a bubble where everything
is there's nothing's no one's
challenging bad ideas that we can get
there any of us I'm sure it happens with
me on this podcast in terms of like
people I invite it's like oh you fall in
line with these things that I believe in
so therefore we should do a podcast
together and keep it election selection
by it how do you break that with your
post like I'm sure you fall and I just
said it's alright I always I'm gonna
read a ton of skepticism about any
opinion I have what is that doing think
about how we do this okay the
marketplace of ideas the idea isn't that
the idea is that it's the it's
specifically the clash of ideas that the
dust settles and truth is left right we
the clash of ideas helps us teachers now
think about a courtroom a courtroom has
one attorney that is full selection bias
cherry-picking Trump
by us of every kind intentionally as
their job of getting to one conclusion
is no defense attorney that says you
know the prosecution's made some good
points actually I think like that's good
to know
their job is to be one sided yeah but
because you have both of them you have
the clash and the jury can maybe start
to see after watching them clash with
the treaty so with cryonics like I said
I'm gonna read once I don't to read the
skeptics as much as I can by the time
they're done clashing it's not that I
know for sure just like the jury doesn't
know for sure I'm gonna have a hunch I'm
gonna start to feel like these people
are the other ones who are much more
fact-based here hmm these people have
thought about this more these people are
talking in more reasonable words they
seem to be more humble and and more
whatever it is and so if I'm reading now
in the news we the news is hopeless to
get an objective source don't even try
I'm try to be an objective guy if I
tried to create a news source it's gonna
be biased in some way of my own so what
I will do is I'll read the New York
Times article and I'll go right away and
Google the same thing on National Review
mm-hmm or I'll watch something on MSNBC
and then I'll go try to find a clip on
Fox News pressure be the first pair but
but you know New York Times people get
mad at they think it's biased or Fox or
you know one of these it's just if you
just treat it like one of the attorneys
it's fine it's serving its role the
problem is when people treat it like the
grand truth like this objective truth so
instead it's what I find is when I read
I've become through this post and I'm
not gonna stop now I read a ton of
conservative media along with my
standard kind of you know left-wing
media and together I just get a healthy
degree of skepticism it makes it very
hard for me to feel very convicted about
a lot of quickshow about anything
because if you only read one thing you
could say this is obviously true when
I'm saying I heard a really smart good
argument by a really smart person saying
this wasn't true and this was overblown
and that this was a made-up stat and I
and so you end up feeling very humble
which isn't feel good all the time but
it feels at least like honest and I I
don't feel delusional I don't feel like
I'm in some bubble anymore so
I think that's how we can do this is you
know I if you have guests on a podcast
get some people on that fundamentally
disagree with you not just on what's
gonna happen but think differently
that's really you know and just examine
their branding you put it out in the
table and examine the way they think
either you'll still disagree with the
way they think but you'll understand
them better afterwards which can then
lead you to be able to convince much you
know change minds better if you
understand or they'll poke some hole in
your logic or humble you out a little
bit in a way that will make you it'll
hurt at the time it'll make you a better
thinker in the long run or they'll
literally point out a way you're wrong
or you'll do something likewise to them
but but for your listeners right they'll
benefit a ton from that I love you know
intelligence squared is this debate
podcast
I'd much rather learn something in the
form of a debate than in the form of one
person because now you just it's like a
courtroom to me yeah and a jury you know
okay I get to be a jury with both sides
well that's why I've fallen into the
longer form podcast because you really
learn how someone thinks instead of
their edited like sound clip version so
one of the like the hotly debated in
contested topics or is cryptocurrency
right now Julian asked on Twitter do you
have thoughts or strong opinions
definitely no strong opinions I have
read a little bit I get more requests
for this topic than I've gotten about
anything
has three months might give me fall
crazy yeah and I do think it's a good
way polite topic I don't right now have
the time at this moment but I do wanna
dive in because it's exactly the kind of
topic I like which is this is important
this is extremely complex and it's in
it's incredibly hard to understand from
an 800 word article which is what
everyone writes yep but it's not
actually that hard to understand in a
10,000 word article so to me it's like I
it's not that this is that complicated
it's not that that you need to be super
smart it's just it needs to be really
thoroughly explained no one's doing that
very well and this is important yeah I
was and I think cryonics and pretty
machine interfaces and many other things
I've taken on so
from what I've read the best analogy the
best like metaphor that pops into my
head for what this seems like and I
think out that all changes I research
more is it seems like it's 1988 and
there's not one internet but there's
many different interwebs compete
competitor interwebs kind of trying to
start and maybe none of them will take
hold in the whole thing will you know
end up not existing or there'll be many
of them multiple or there'll be one that
ends up becoming this giant thing like
the internet and I think the people
buying crypto-currency right now is kind
of like buying domain names on various
ones of these and hoping that they take
off so maybe there's an inter web but
not mean even any websites on it yet but
there's domain names you can buy and
you're taking a lottery ticket that
maybe this is gonna become the Internet
and then I'll have this super valuable
currency but I also think that's
probably like explaining like magnets is
like having a rubber band where it's
like yes it tells you what the basic
deal is but it's actually fundamentally
different than what's really happening
so I think when I research more I will
probably reject my own metaphor as as
maybe a first starting point but then it
needs to be explained further why this
is not actually like that because it is
but but I think it's a really cool
concept I think that we right now assume
that the only way to do things is
centralized systems governments
centralized governments these trusted
Authority units we can all kind of hang
on to for safety and for like
organization and you know governments we
invented that you know that you know
countries are invented let you know
pretty recently page 497 we started
having countries basically so though of
course there'll be other paradigms big
things are gonna change and you know I'm
sure that the the way that the mining
happens right now and things like this
is gonna look very primitive they'll
come up with different ways especially
when you have other kind of interfaces
you have brain-machine interfaces for
example we may be able to come up with
very you know just the way that no of
eye scanner
fingerprints weight faster than like a
password it's way more we might come up
with things that are even cooler ways to
kind of verify transactions and
everything like that and records but um
I'm very intrigued and I think it is
definitely worth understanding and
starting to think about I think anyone
investing right now you know I think has
to be aware that like you know it could
be amazing but like very good chance
that like any one of these currencies it
just becomes nothing and I think that
people know that so but I think it's
just so cool it's fascinating and I
think I think understanding it starts
with understanding kind of the
blockchain concept and I think that
starts with understanding encryption and
just literally how the encryption works
and you know the public key and the
private key and when I when I dug into
that of the law I started to like it
started to make sense and I started to
say I see it otherwise that people they
hear about this like mythical ledger on
computers and they just tune out because
they think I don't know what does that
mean once you get what it means it
starts to be kind of delicious so I
think that that's it's a great topic or
they think it's just this fake thing
that you're buying into only prices
rising and so you're gonna make money
that way where there's or they
one-dimensional eyes it as this is just
like a different kind of currency but
it's not it's the currency itself is one
of many kinds of things that can happen
in a decentralized system so yeah I have
a two-week reading stretch and ahead of
me there and I'll come out of that and
I'll have way better answer for you okay
cool and so I just want to wrap up with
one more question from Facebook so Casey
Sten asked you gave an awesome talk
about AI in Carmel it sounds like in May
and what incredibly complex technology
that's coming needs our attention what's
something that all of us should know or
think about yeah there's a lot there's a
lot right now I mean it's exciting it's
overwhelming so I think I'm gonna name a
few okay I think I mean I think crypto
is one of one thing to think about
things that might be as big a deal as
the internet in 10 years is kind of how
I'm thinking about it
or way bigger I think so you know you
know there's this hype kind of
trajectory that goes big big you know
something first starts to actually work
as a technology massive pipe then it's
not really ready for primetime yet
though and everyone gets everyone just
suddenly becomes like oh everyone that
the you know everyone's over that it's
never gonna work right and then it
creeps back in as a actual existing
thing so we've had a I and a few
different of these bumps
I think VR AR is one of these there was
a big stretch a couple years ago you
know oculus is new and the vive and you
know you people are doing these cool
demos and you know you have first a are
kind of big explosion with Pokemon go
and you have the Google cardboard you
know and you have samsung gear and all
this stuff right and I think it was huge
hype and now you don't hear much about
it right now it's it's in a dead period
because it was the only way to do it
well is he's really expensive you had to
get a fancy computer and a fancy thing
they were hard to even get they were
backlogged the the headsets and you had
to be tethered to your computer you had
to put stuff on the walls I did all this
so I know and and then you got in them
and sometimes they made you nauseous
there were some programs that were
unbelievable and I was just blown away
that this is one point O this is ms-dos
and it's so good already but a lot of
them weren't that good a lot of them
made you nauseous the headset it's
exhausting to have on for the long time
it's heavy take it off you're sweating
and now all I'm thinking the whole time
is people in ten years are gonna look at
you know I'm gonna go to my closet and
pull out my 51.0 they're gonna say oh my
God look how big this is you could put
it oughta be like oh my god you were
this and it's gonna seem like you know
the cell phone in a briefcase yeah so
but I've done this a lot more than most
because I was I'm gonna write a post on
and I went to the oculus conference I've
tried all the basically all of the
programs and I was just floored by how
awesome this is VR knows even getting to
air which is probably even bigger
concept you know the magic leap stuff
and just things were you just whether
it's through headset or glasses or
eventually contact lenses
never you actually can you know you just
add stuff on to your world your whole
computer interface is just floating
there in front of you and whatever it is
I'm you know a lot of things we can't
even imagine so I think that those I
think that that the implications for
gaming and entertainment but also for
you know just kind of experiences for
for communication for training for you
know building empathy and for you know
the classroom of third graders in the
you in in Missouri going on a fun-filled
trip to the moon with a class from third
graders in Saudi Arabia and coming back
and like this is good for empathy this
is good for the world right yeah you
know being able to sit around with your
grandmother even though she died 40
years ago and sit there at the table
like she's there and you're just
watching her look at you and laugh and
you're having a conversation that you
know you're watching the conversation
that took place so this is I can go on
many many examples but I was in that
headset and I also learned enough about
like what's coming with the technology
out the headsets are gonna get it's very
much smaller they're gonna stop needing
to be tethered to something and needing
to have things on the wall you're gonna
have cameras on the actual headset
they're gonna see the walls and it's
just gonna get better and better and
better and batteries are gonna get
better and the computers and you get
better so we're gonna end up I think in
10 years with a billion people using VR
a billion like it's gonna be the new
kind of smart phone or cell phone mm-hmm
and you know a young entrepreneurs who
want to get into you know something
that's new you know this is a heaven
start of your company when it's not
being talked about started start
developing start making really good
things you know or AR or whatever it is
and when the headsets are ready and when
suddenly you know there's a killer kind
of headset that's in everyone's pocket
and it ends up you know all over the
world you're gonna be one of them you're
gonna you know you'll be in the position
to be Google you know there's the Larry
Page and Mark Zuckerberg of the VR world
like they don't they don't exist you
don't will they probably exist but yeah
yeah they're not they're not famous yet
unless unless you know I mean I know
that Mark Zuckerberg also wants to be
the Mark Zuckerberg of the but there's
gonna be new you know Giants and they're
not there yet so that's one another one
I would just say quickly is um you know
Jeanette
stuff crisper and all that I mean it
costs I think it was almost two billion
dollars he was almost three billion
dollars like 20 years ago to sequence
the human genome and today it's like 50
bucks okay things are about to get
really crazy I mean we I think that your
grandkids are gonna be born here your
grandkids are gonna say to you you just
had a baby and hoped it was a good baby
it's gonna seem crazy he's gonna seem so
old-school
yeah it's gonna be just you know and
only the crazy hippies are gonna be like
we just have a natural base in the way
it is and people are gonna hate them
like anti-vaxxers like you're a horrible
parent you know you should never did so
and and all the implications of this
enhancing ourselves creating you know
just just getting rid of disease
creating smarter people I mean you can
really go on and on and on there you'll
have you'll have four people like two
couples decide to make a baby the four
of them really kind of cool [ __ ] so if
that really gets rolling we're gonna
look back to the world when you know you
just had normal pee also so I did this I
have research but like pregnancy is god
it's gotta go it's crazy
yeah once we once we have that you you
you incubate the fetus the embryo and
you in in this perfect chamber that has
all the mothers you know y'all destruct
all the mothers hormones all the
mother's blood and so it's not like this
it has all this exact same chemicals
that would be going into it but the
perfect diet it's monitored perfectly
and the mother gets to live her normal
life and then it doesn't have to the
fact it would be that way your your
grandmother gave birth like an animal
like it was she was pregnant she gave
birth like out of her vagina like an
animal it's gonna seem so primitive and
then you know so anyway you can go on
and on I mean I think brain-machine
interfaces is another huge one I think
broke no one is talking about Mars right
now give it five years there's gonna be
humans on Mars in a decade no one
realizes this okay we're you know the
amount of leaps for all of life on Earth
that you can say are as big as gold
multiplanetary there's like simple cell
to complex cell complex cell to multi
cell organism multi cell like animal -
out of the ocean
on land multiplanetary I mean this is so
big and it's happening in our lifetimes
it's so exciting and it's gonna be the
new kind of moon decade it's gonna be
the new ones yeah 20s is the new 60 so
lots of exciting things this is why
people should probably go go into some
kind of tech and-and-and the word Tech
is it you know they should they should
move to California or other places it
may be Austin has a scene Boulder but
they should get involved in the future
cuz it's like we're inventing this new
planet that we're all gonna live on so
and I would also say just don't be
intimidated to learn like similar to you
just like go for it
you just get it's easy to get involved
and it's also easy to get scared and I
don't think people should be scared plus
a lot of other people think they need to
be great at math or coding totally a lot
of what we need are smart philosophers
smart you know people can make great
metaphors people who can who can you
know talk about ethics you know
something but we just you know it
doesn't matter what you're good at like
you ever role to play in this I mean
being pretty good at two things means
you're extraordinary at that one thing
absolutely and that's like exactly
exactly so I mean right you can you know
some people go for breath and then you
offer something different you see a big
picture that other people don't like the
sci-fi author or you get really into
depth on one thing and then you really
are whatever it is like there's a role
there's definitely a role maybe maybe
your job is communicating what's
happening to other people like me so
yeah I think that people need to just
get excited and scared at the same time
which is gonna fire them up so alright
man thanks for coming in ok thank you
you